وايرا مثل كل المسالك الصحراء كانما لم
يخلق لغير قوافل الجمال يبدو الطريق الى
ولا تاب
رغم هذه العزله الخانقه وما خلفه الزمن
الغابر من نتوب تحتفظ المدينه باثر مما
كانت عليه في سلف الزمان وتولد حنينا في
بعض النفوس
هذا ما يعيد حمود الى بيت عاش فيه اجداده
عبر قرون منزل ما يزال يحتفظ رغم تبدل
السكان بالنمط المعماري الولاتي الاصيل
القديمه من السكان وتحريم الاوضاع
الامنيته في دوله مال المجاوره وتصني
منطقه الحمراء من طرف الدول الغربيه سكان
المدينه
اثنين عدسيه
كامله
خارج الوطن خلال العصور الوسطى من التاريخ
الاسلامي كانت ولادته في قلب التبادلات
التجاريه بين شمال افريقيا وما عرف ببلاد
السودان فتره شهده ازدهار الثقافيا وبرزا
المواطن معماريه فريده من نوعها في هذه
الرب الرب
هذه البيوت الاخيره
وفيها المخزن كتوا يستخدموها الولايات
اساسا فتره الحرب
لائقه للسكن فتره الصيف ولا تقتصر ذاكره
المدينه على ايام القوافل والترحال ففي
هذه القلعه سجن المختار اول رئيس للبلادي
بعد اطاحته نهايه السبعينيات وهنا لفظ
قاده من الحركه
الزوجات
رغم عديت الزمن وهجرته اغلب السكان يتشبث
من باقه هنا بتراث المدينه ويواصلون
الحياه وفقا مواطن معيشيه اشتهرت بها منذ
قرون جهود تحاول ان تحفظها للمدينه بعضا
من الالقا كان لهذا اليوم وتصون تراثا على
شفا الدثار الجزيره موريتانيا